powerful hairdo what up Brendan in deal
this is Alex from Austin Texas and I got
a debate club for you who was better the
Power Rangers or the Ninja Turtles
buzz buzz gang gang gang bruh
buzz buzz dog what's too easy for me bro
it's too easy for you yeah then Power
Rangers jumping them ty it's all gay and
[ __ ] listen the turtles worth a [ __ ] man
the turtles [ __ ] Michelangelo all of
them you named the turtles yes I can't
go Michelangelo um
Donatello yes that's the tricky one yeah
Leonardo and uh I want to say Bonacci
who is it
Donatello Raphael Michelangelo Leonardo
Donatello Jesus we are done man and the
last one they all sound the same don't
they Raphael there are four baby turtles
yeah well I don't like here's ala
obviously you know they got shredder my
dog shredder out there yeah dr. shredder
you know and r.i.p a lot of people no he
died a couple months ago mm-hmm boy
they're cool man pizza turtles that's
true it's easy bro it's so easy I
originally showed up you know they got a
couple of you know the Power Rangers it
was a gay pride parade I got all that
wood or they got horses in the back and
make a rainbow then they're in tights
all of a sudden I got the [ __ ] it was a
kid I was like what's happening right
now yeah
strange yeah Power Rangers yeah I didn't
know what they showed up like they yeah
it seemed a little vague you couldn't
know you didn't know who was who what
were they defending yeah no we don't we
know the turtles were defend they were
the sewer and the rat their master
discipline pizza April's fine ass yeah
the Rat King let's go to the culture for
what you guys think because I think
Brennan is you know all day bro those
guys for sure get [ __ ] power rain isn't
getting no [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
man our diversity brother green the
green power inch pre diverse - it had an
asian chick a black dude oh that's true
dude but you could a gym sometimes could
you you can't see any of them really
yeah cat are you a Power Ranger fan
I mean I feel like I have to be because
oh yeah oh you're younger
no that was around the time I was
growing up I weren't there like Power
Rangers like ninjas or samurai some [ __ ]
like that
yeah I feel like they just represented
more Asian people so I you have to be on
their team I could see that kicking
jumping off of stuff electricity coming
off of them that's Asian stuff dude
that's like an anime style kind of Moreh
ninja there's lots more Asian than a
ninja yeah Master Splinter was a Asian
but did they train that much or anything
like a lot of times they one of them was
lazy I think water-wise a him they did
Drive a van with Casey and April April 4
9 a.m. tee top dude April had them
freakin double tortoise haters in the
front yeah dang bro if you had a bangin
dude I would freak yeah yellow jumpsuit
remember oh I put on a diaper and shave
my head and pretend I was a baby dude to
get on that tit you know it so what are
the people saying shut out the Turtles
Oh 74% Ninja Turtles so yeah no [ __ ]
speaking Power Rangers
what else you whoo 26% audience who is
obviously cats talkers
[Laughter]
back up my broccolini get your life
together I'm not